marina les chroniqueurs ont voulu vous
faire plaisir donc je rappelle que vous
êtes là pour nous présenter l'album qui
sortira au mois d'octobre je le rappelle
il en a la chance d'avoir cette petite
merveille qui est d'ores et déjà en
vente
on my own mais on a voulu savoir qui
était c'est votre tube emblématique le
meilleur chanteur de homeless donc trois
vont concourir et c'est vous qui allez
choisir
votez sur twitter
je suis un battant rencontres depuis le
début parce que on vient de s'apercevoir
d'une chose c'est que c'est ok rockets
mais elle ne sait pas lire
donc ça complet que j'ai pas du trouvère
en tête est-ce que vous pouvez juste
prendre le tout début c'est la musique
attention est la tienne
il est
non
[Musique]
internet c'est un massage
c'est terminé malheureusement c'est bien
parce qu'à un moment donné
[Musique]
et là haut tu as
est-ce que là
omer
les séquelles
elle
car les données maxime et puis des
concerts parisiens
l'audi side qui l'aimé
[Musique]
l'arménie
à
hong lei
et ça
une eau
ep
s
[Musique]
m
locaux
tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
m
e
[Musique]
ce que
mm
et de temps
mais
la consommer
les étoilés
moment là
vdk
une heure
signal
merci merci beaucoup mais j'étais obligé
de stopper car on m'annonce que 40
affiche une baisse était de collecter
s'était bien passé
pouvez vous nous expliquer ce qu'il
fallait faire marina il nous fredonner
voilà ce que vous auriez dû rentrer à ce
que vous avez entendu ou la micro ou
vous le faites avec celui d'un ange mais
le refrain oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà en quoi le devrait
c'est énorme alors qui vient viol s'est
passé un truc et jim carrey ce qui vous
a regardé % vous étiez une candidate
[Applaudissements]